okay so in this quick video we're going
to go over the basics of the carbon
cycle now the picture shows the
greenhouse effect now please do not
think that there is an actual glass
building surrounding planet Earth that's
just silly
but the picture is kind of implying that
our atmosphere acts like a greenhouse
our atmosphere is made up of a lot of
carbon dioxide and carbon dioxide acts
like a greenhouse to trap heat well
we're going to go into that a little
more detail in a little bit let's go
ahead and get started though with the
carbon cycle
so when we look at the carbon cycle one
thing to remind ourselves is that carbon
the element called carbon carbon is the
basis of organic molecules and if you
recall there's four broad categories of
organic molecules the first bein
proteins the picture hopefully can
remind you from earlier in the school
year that proteins are made from long
chains of amino acids and we think of
foods that are high in protein fish are
high in protein eggs are high in protein
steaks are high in protein another
organic molecule category are
carbohydrates the the picture you see
here is c6h12o6 if you want to count up
the carbons there should be six of them
12 hydrogen's and six oxygens in the
picture but this is glucose which is a
carbohydrate made by the process of
photosynthesis we think of foods that
are high in carbohydrates perhaps pastas
come in to mind and fruits come in to
mind a third category of organic
molecules would be lipids the picture
here shows a phospholipid bilayer it's
the outer boundary of cells so the basic
unit of life cells the outer layer of
cells is made from lipids and then we
think of the fourth category of organic
molecules I hope we remember nucleic
acids the picture here shows a DNA helix
a double helix DNA molecule so I hope
I've given you some really good reasons
why a knowledge of the carbon cycle is
really important let's go ahead and go
through the stages
so when we look at the stages of the
carbon cycle let's start off with plants
and producers in my animation we have a
plant absorbing carbon dioxide plants
have little tiny microscopic pores on
the underside of their leaves called
stomata and when these stomata when
these pores are open they can take in
carbon dioxide it's one of the it's one
of the requests it's one of the needs
one of the requirements of
photosynthesis along with water along
with sunlight so they'll take in carbon
dioxide and they'll produce glucose
glucose the formula c6h12o6 is created
via photosynthesis
well now the carbon in the form of
glucose is simply going to move up the
food chain
so when we now focus on animals animals
represented by the rabbit and the wolf
in the animation here glucose simply
moves up the food chain in the animation
glucose is going from the plant to the
rabbit well that's because the rabbit is
eating the plant it's taking glucose
from the plant well it simply moves up
the food chain the wolf is getting
glucose from the rabbit in the animation
because the wolf is eating the rabbit so
the glucose simply moves up the food
chain well let's not forget that animals
give off carbon dioxide so in the
animation the rabbit the wolf they're
exhaling carbon dioxide and if you look
we've already got a little cycle we've
already got a little carbon cycle in the
animation and we're saying we're not a
hundred percent finished but you can
already see the beginning here of the
carbon cycle well let's move on to the
mushrooms in the picture
so the mushrooms in the picture are
symbolic of decomposers fungus and
bacteria and so like it says decomposes
obtain glucose by feeding on the dead so
in the animation glucose is going from
the wolf from the rabbit and from the
plant because when wolves rabbits plants
and other organisms die there remains
become food for decomposers such as
fungus such as bacteria well fungus and
bacteria they also give off carbon
dioxide because they have mitochondria I
should say the fungus has mitochondria
bacteria do not but all organisms give
off carbon dioxide as a form of waste
here and so when the decomposers feed
and the dead remains they also give off
carbon dioxide it's part of their
cellular waste and so you can see we
have a nice carbon cycle going in this
animation or there's one more factor we
need to mention briefly
and so the last factor I want to mention
briefly is the human contribution in the
animation we have a factory in the
background giving off a bunch of carbon
dioxide so the human contribution to the
carbon cycle is that excess carbon
dioxide is being released into the
atmosphere from the burning of fossil
fuels such as coal oil and natural gas
we burn coal oil and natural gas of
course to produce electricity
electricity for homes for factories and
so this is producing a whole lot of
carbon dioxide that is going into the
atmosphere and so the earth has never
seen really this large amount of carbon
dioxide being released into the
atmosphere so right now our concern is
that the carbon cycle is out of balance
not only are we releasing too much
carbon dioxide into the environment but
we're also cutting down deforesting
trees and other plants that can take
carbon dioxide out of the air and so
some of the some of the fears is that
this could upset the climate patterns
around the world causing a problem
called global warming or climate change
this video is not going to go into
global warming and climate change but I
have another video on that topic if you
want to if you're curious about it
so if we look at this animation right
here this is kind of just a summary
animation you can see hopefully a neat
little cycle going on between the
producers between the animals and
between the decomposers so this is just
kind of the wrap up here the the wrap up
animation showing the carbon cycle and
so here we have a little practice quiz
if you're in my biology class pause the
video and bring me your answer is either
before school or after school I'd love
to check them for accuracy go ahead and
pause the video good luck